the family leslie palacio continues the
call for justice this after jose rangel
the father of the man accused of killing
her
pleaded guilty to destroying evidence in
the case he's facing
two years in prison but for palacio's
family that time is not nearly enough
they say they are speaking out in a
peaceful protest downtown
that's where we have madison kimbrough
live with the very latest hi madison
friends and family gathered here for
leslie as you can see right beside us
here at the regional justice center
for the 22 year old woman who was killed
last august
you can see they are all standing by
with signs and other media in tow
this past week jose rangel pleaded
guilty to destroying evidence
and being an accessory to murder in
palacio's death
in a video first obtained by the i-team
rangel is seen helping his son
move palacio's body and covering up the
crime scene
he apparently washed the blood off of
his driveway after her body was dragged
his son eric rangel ibarra is still on
the run
but jose rangel struck a plea deal and
is now facing up to two years in prison
today's protest is to try to convince
the court otherwise
that ringell deserves a longer sentence
since he was very much
a part of her death so as you can see
things are just getting underway here
you can see there is signage there are
also
people just standing by in support of
leslie this was supposed to take place
around 3
30 but it looks like it's just starting
now of course we will bring you the
latest details as we are going to be
here all afternoon so keep it here on 8
news now
reporting live from downtown madison
kimbrough 8 news now